Traductor: Sebastian Betti
En 1864, el zoólogo francés
August Duméril
quedó desconcertado mientras
investigaba al ajolote.
A diferencia de muchos otros anfibios,
que se transforman en adultos terrestres,
los ajolotes conservan su características
juveniles y nunca salen del agua.
En un intento por inducir la metamorfosis
Duméril pasó meses
quitándoles las branquias.
Pero en la mayoría de los casos, los
ajolotes simplemente... las regeneraban.
De hecho, los ajolotes son maestros
de la regeneración:
Pueden regenerar perfectamente
partes del cuerpo.
de miembros amputados y espinas
aplastadas a partes de ojos y el cerebro.
Entonces ¿cómo lo hacen?
¿Y qué otros secretos guardan?
Esta salamandra extraordinaria es nativa
de los humedales de la Ciudad de México.
Los antiguos aztecas lo consideraban
la encarnación de un dios llamado Xolotl;
de ahí el nombre del ajolote,
que significa “monstruo del agua”.
Los ajolotes alcanzan la madurez sexual
con branquias y una aleta dorsal
parecida a un renacuajo.
Los científicos piensan que su eterna
juventud, llamada "neotenia",
evolucionó debido a su hábitat estable.
Para salamandras que se desarrollan
en aguas que se secan,
la transición eficiente a la tierra
es esencial.
Pero los ajolotes desarrollados en lagos
eran invariables durante todo el año,
lagos que no albergaban
muchos depredadores acuáticos.
Los científicos creen que fue ventajoso
para el ajolote
renunciar a las exigencias
de la metamorfosis.
Sin embargo, no han perdido por completo
esta habilidad.
De exponerse a ciertas sustancias,
el ajolote llegará a adulto.
Pero a menudo tendrá
esperanza de vida más corta
y perderá algo de sus habilidades
de autocuración.
Para empezar, esta regeneración
pareciera ser un superpoder antojadizo,
pero los ajolotes hacen
muy buen uso del mismo.
De bebés, están en competencia directa.
Entonces, se comen el uno al otro.
Por lo general, esto no es un gran
problema gracias a la rapidez
con la que pueden regenerar
partes del cuerpo.
Cuando un ajolote pierde una extremidad,
los tejidos estimulan
el crecimiento en la zona.
Las células de la piel se dividen
y cubren la herida.
Luego, las células progenitoras,
que pueden desarrollarse
en varios tejidos corporales,
forman una masa en el sitio de la lesión
y los nervios cercanos secretan
proteínas promotoras del crecimiento.
En las próximas semanas
emerge una nueva extremidad
conforme las células proliferan
y se diferencian coordinadamente.
Este proceso podría en potencia llevar
a un crecimiento descontrolado
y formación de tumores.
Pero los ajolotes son notablemente
resistentes al cáncer.
Tienen un sistema que controla firmemente
la proliferación celular.
Para comprender mejor esta biología
desconcertante del ajolote
los científicos secuenciaron su genoma.
Descubrieron que era más de diez veces
más largo que el de un humano.
Las mutaciones pueden cambiar la longitud
del genoma de cualquier animal.
Como sea, las salamandras tienen
mucho más ADN que otros vertebrados
porque pierden partes de ADN
con menos frecuencia.
Al investigar el genoma del ajolote
los científicos vieron
muchas secuencias repetidas,
la mayoría de las cuales
no codifican proteínas
y no tienen ninguna función conocida.
También encontraron genes
clave epara la regeneración.
Sin embargo, el factor más importante
de la regeneración del ajolote
puede que no sea un conjunto de genes
únicos, sino cómo regulan sus genes.
No es de extrañar que los ajolotes sean
uno de los animales más estudiados
por la ciencia.
Pero su población en estado silvestre
se ha desplomado.
Hace cientos de años, los ajolotes
proliferaban en la capital azteca.
En los lagos circundantes
los aztecas construyeron islas llamadas
chinampas, para cultivos.
Esta forma de agricultura
altamente productiva
creó un vasto sistema de canales,
expandiendo el hábitat de sistema lacustre
poco profundo y protegido,
el entorno ideal de los ajolotes.
Pero cuando llegaron
los invasores españoles,
comenzaron a drenar los lagos.
Y en los últimos años
se ha desviado más agua.
Hoy toda la población
de ajolotes silvestres
se encuentra en un solo lugar,
el lago de Xochimilco,
donde están amenazados
por la contaminación
y los peces invasores.
La gente trabaja para regenerar
el ecosistema
y fortalecer los 2000 años
de tradición agrícola de la chinampa.
Si crece el interés, los agricultores
podrían recuperar chinampas abandonadas
y apoyar a la comunidad local...
y al ajolote.
Eventualmente, los beneficios de salvar
a esta salamandra podrían ser aún mayores.
Los científicos esperan
que algún día podamos aplicar
la magistral supresión tumoral del ajolote
y sus habilidades regenerativas
al cuerpo humano.
Quizás sus secretos
sean la verdadera razón
de la sonrisa del monstruoso dios viscoso.